paul wesley
boyd
première émission des manifestations
devant je ne connais pas eric zemmour je
connais pas je ne sais pas je sais même
pas quoi ressemblera démission mes deux
genoux à terre dans les toilettes je ne
sais pas où je vais mais je sais que tu
vas te débrouiller l'éternel est mon
berger
je ne manquerai de rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à chaque fois je me dis mais c'est ce
sujet là qu'on va aborder qu'est ce que
je pourrais bien dire je me tais dieu tu
prends les rênes
c'est facile à dire mais c'est la
première fois que je l'expérimenté
vraiment je me suis complètement effacée
derrière dieu et je les laissais piloter
à neuf tout piloter
[Musique]
et je lui ai dit si tu m'envoies là
c'est que tu as une mission je sais pas
laquelle régulièrement même dans
l'émission ponctuellement quand il y
avait une ouverture
lancer un petit versets bibliques enfin
j'ai des pasteurs qui m'écrivent madame
qui ai dit vous avez osé
oui